mrs. eva school you know what a Scoville
is it's a scale that measures the spicy
heat of chili peppers and similar foods
and the spiciest new CF model is the
Cupra the engine boasts nearly 200
horsepower and it gets a top speed of
more than 230 km/h the Cupra can zip
from 0 to 100 km/h in just 6.7 seconds
the first cupra model rolled off the
assembly line nearly 10 years ago this
model boasts a 141 kilowatt engine the
XDS electronic differential lock and
adjustable damping controls these
features really set the Cooper apart it
has a 1.8 liter turbocharged gasoline
engine and the engineers have improved
the combustion process and increase the
torque all this means better performance
and the Cooper's fun to drive to
especially out of the countryside d
father otto testified ho Dyson hofer
says driving the ibiza cooper reminds
him of the first Golf GTI it was light
and powerful a great combination but the
Cupra is even better and it's a lot of
fun to drive the interior design is
conservative everything's laid out
precisely and there are lots of custom
options available for example the
ventilation rings come in different
colors so does the seat upholstery
unfortunate avocado doll diz it's Beluga
publish one touch Italy stand outside
there have been a few changes take a
look at the newly designed grill the
car's got a real sporty look you can
adjust the chassis at the touch of a
button with the new dynamic chassis
control feature the XDS electronic
limited-slip differential and proves the
Cupra stability especially in curves
then I fine art says the new he beats a
Cooper offers lots of improvements it's
easier to drive in the city but can also
have a more sporty feel if desired the
Ford Fiesta ST or the Mini Cooper S look
more brawny by comparison and the
exhaust note is a little muted